the strongest Demon Slayer yorichi
tsugikuni is the most important person
in the entire story and by the end of
this video you will know everything
there is to know about the strongest
character in Demon Slayer you'll be able
to brag to your friends about how much
more Demon Slayer knowledge you have
compared to them you will learn all of
yurichi's powers and secrets and you
will know exactly why even demon daddy
muzon ran away in fear from this
mysterious man by the time that yorichi
is officially introduced in the story he
was already built up as an absolute
Legend after seeing tanjiro's hanafuda
earrings during the asakusa Arc muzan
remembers yorichi standing over him
after he utterly defeated him in battle
this memory triggers an intense fear
within muzon in fact muzon is so afraid
of yorichi that his very DNA has PTSD
and while is fighting tanjiro during the
Entertainment District Arc she feels a
crippling fear coming from muzon's blood
cells after she Witnesses tanjiro using
hinokami kagura which reminds muzon
cells of yorichi's breath of the Sun but
if yorichi is this overpowered monster
who makes even muzon shutter and fear
then why does his official introduction
to the story show him in a state of
depression why does he tell his friend
sumioshi that he is worthless a man
without value and a man who failed to
accomplish the one thing that he was
meant to do in this life in order to
understand this strange situation we
have to go back to the beginning
actually scratch that we have to go
about 480 years before the beginning of
the main Demon Slayer story if you guys
enjoy our Demon Slayer videos and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment right now to help
us with that YouTube algorithm and if
you are one of the over 50 of people who
watch our videos but haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a big favor
and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications subscribing
on YouTube is completely free but it
helps me out a lot finally this video
will contain Demon Slayer manga spoilers
we are looking at all the available
information about yorichi so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned yorichi tsugikuni was born nearly
five centuries ago During the sengoku
period of Japanese history the sengoku
period is also known as the Warring
States period because it was full of
civil wars and social unrest it was a
very dangerous time it was a very
unstable time and it was a time before
science a time of myth and Superstition
yorichi was born into an important
Samurai family as the younger of two
twin boys being born a twin was already
considered a bad Omen during this super
dishes time because twins are
essentially the same age and this could
lead to a power struggle when it comes
time for one of the two sons to inherit
the wealth and status of the family
during an unstable time like the sengoku
period disputes over which sun will
succeed the current head of an important
family could lead to a bloody Civil War
and so the father of yorichi and
michikatsu which was the name of the
older twin brother decided that
eliminating yorichi may be the best
thing to do the fact that yorichi was
born with a large and unusual birthmark
on his face only Amplified the
superstitious fears of his father and so
little yorichi came very close to losing
his life when he was still just a baby
thankfully yorichi's mother was a strong
Brave and stubborn woman and she refused
to allow her husband to harm yorichi she
became so aggressive and angry at the
mere mention of such a thing that her
husband had no choice but to spare
yorichi's life the family agreed that
instead of killing yorichi they would
simply ship him off to a religious
Temple when he reached the age of 10.
when he becomes a monk at the age of 10
yorichi will be required to renounce his
worldly possessions anyway and so he
will renounce any claims that he might
have to his family's status and property
this would then leave michikatsu the
older brother as the only legitimate
Heir and since it was decided right then
and there that michikatsu would one day
take over as the head of the family
while yorichi would leave the family and
go off to live in a temple the two twin
boys were raised completely differently
michikatsu was raised to become the
successor and he got the best education
the best clothes the best food and the
best living quarters but yorichi who
would only be with the family for a few
years before renouncing all his Earthly
possessions to become a monk was raised
in accommodations more akin to that of a
servant than a member of the family he
had a small room that was separated from
the rest of the house his clothes were
simple his food was basic and his
education was almost non-existent and so
while michikatsu trained to become a
samurai like his father yurichi spent
most of his time with his mother and he
was often clinging to her left side like
some kind of baby michikatsu saw this as
a sign that yorichi was weak and
cowardly and he pitied his younger
brother but he didn't dislike his
younger brother on the contrary he would
take risks just to go out and see his
brother and play with him their father
didn't want michikatsu getting attached
to yorichi but michikatsu's knockoff to
visit yorichi's room behind his father's
back and because he couldn't give any of
his own belongings to yorichi since
their father would notice and get mad
michikatsu carved a wooden flute for
your Ichi and gave it to him as a gift
actually michikatsu secretly made that
flute the day after his father hit him
across the face for attempting to give a
different gift to yorichi yorichi didn't
speak or smile until the age of seven
leading most people to conclude that he
must be deaf and perhaps also mentally
deficient in some way his mother was
very concerned about him so she made him
a pair of hanafuda earrings as good luck
charms but one day when the Twins were
seven years of age the fact that yurichi
wasn't deaf or deficient in any way
became extremely clear to michikatsu and
to everyone else in the entire household
on this particular day the older brother
michikatsu was engaged in Sword practice
with a professional instructor yorichi
suddenly asked his brother if his dream
was to become the strongest Samurai in
the nation and michikatsu was so
surprised to hear his brother speak that
he dropped his wooden Practice Sword
also known as a Balkan to his brother's
further surprise yurichi then said that
he also wanted to become a samurai
michikatsu knew that this was impossible
because yorichi would be shipped off to
a temple when he turned 10 but even if
that weren't the case michikatsu felt
that his brother simply wasn't cut out
to be a samurai he was a Meek and quiet
boy who always clung to his mother's
side and Mama's Boys are not exactly
Samurai material by this time michikatsu
had developed a clear impression of his
younger brother and even though he cared
for his brother he believed him to be a
weak Boy Who depends on his mommy for
everything on the other hand michikatsu
saw himself as the true heir to his
father the boy who was training to be a
manly samurai warrior unfortunately for
michikatsu his preconceived notions
about himself and his brother would soon
be shattered yorichi started hanging out
with michikatsu whenever he was
practicing sword fighting their father's
vassal who was an expert swordsman was
serving as michikatsu's swordsmanship
instructor seeing that yorichi was
clearly really interested in
swordsmanship the instructor taught him
a few basic things like how to hold the
sword how to position yourself off and
how to swing the instructor then assumed
a combat stance and invited yorichi to
try and hit him now by this point in
time the seven-year-old michikatsu still
wasn't able to land a single hit on his
instructor no matter how hard he tried
and the instructor probably expected to
see a similar level of skill from
yorichi realistically yorichi should
have been even less skilled since he had
received far less training than his
brother but once yorichi moved to strike
his instructor all of the expectations
that both michikatsu and the instructor
had went right out the window in the
blink of an eye yorichi was able to land
four separate blows on his instructor
yorichi hit him so effectively that the
instructor lost Consciousness and when
he woke up he had fist-sized lumps all
over his body although thankfully no
bones were broken and no vital organs
were injured in this moment yorichi
revealed the true truth that he was an
unrivaled natural Talent someone who was
born to be the ultimate swordsman the
tough and committed training of someone
like michikatsu would never be able to
compare to the raw natural Talent of
someone like yorichi but surprisingly
realizing that he had an incredible
natural gift for swordsmanship didn't
convince yorichi to keep pursuing the
goal of becoming a samurai on the
contrary yorichi hated the feeling of
hitting someone and hurting them with a
sword and so he gave up on the idea
entirely if you become a samurai hurting
people just comes with the territory
especially during the sengoku period and
yorichi wasn't interested in that kind
of life and yet even after yorichi
decided that he no longer wanted to
become a samurai michikatsu kept
questioning him about the secret of his
strength he wanted to know how yorichi
managed to get so powerful without any
formal training and he wanted to learn
from his brother so that he could become
as strong as he was eventually yurichi
explained that before your opponent
attacks his lungs heave you just need to
look closely at the disposition of his
bones the contraction of his muscles and
the flow of his blood this will allow
you to predict your opponent's movements
and strike them in exactly the right
place at exactly the right time yorichi
didn't realize it yet but not only was
he born with a birthmark that we now
know is the Demon Slayer Mark but he was
also born with the ability to see the
transparent world and he was already
using it to his Advantage as a
seven-year-old on top of the power to
see through people's bodies yurichi also
had incredible physical abilities that
were simply leagues above anything that
a normal seven-year-old would possess
including michikatsu michikatsu then
realized that all this time he had
pitied his brother and he had seen
himself as Superior to eurichi in
reality yorichi was far superior
appeared to him and what's worse being
Superior came effortlessly to yorichi
even though michikatsu was a talented
swordsman who worked hard and suffered
greatly to get better and stronger his
progress was like that of a turtle
compared to yorichis michikatsu had
immense admiration for his brother's
talent and he wondered how amazing it
must be to be so blessed in the art of
the sword but despite all that yorichi
wasn't even interested in swordsmanship
anymore whenever his brother talked
about sword fighting yorichi seemed
bored and he was much more interested in
playing board games or flying a kite
than he was in talking about swords this
upset michikatsu because here he was
working his entire short life to improve
his swordsmanship and become a great
Samurai and yet his brother had
unbelievable natural talent for sword
fighting but he didn't even care about
swords it's like he was just squandering
the kind of gift that michikatsu would
kill 4. to make the whole thing even
worse after their father heard that
yorichi had practically superhuman
Talent he decided that yorichi should
become his successor and not michikatsu
suddenly yorichi would be the one
sleeping in the big fancy rooms and
wearing the nice fancy clothes and
michikatsu would be shipped off to the
temple when he turned 10. even though
michikatsu wanted to become a Samurai
and yorichi did not michikatsu's dream
would be denied and yorichi would get
everything that he had been promised or
at least that's how things seemed for a
while nevertheless yorichi preempted
this one night when michikatsu was lying
in bed yurichi appeared and told him
that their mother had died michikatsu
was shocked because he didn't even think
there was anything wrong with their
mother but yorichi simply told him to
ask their mother's servant for the
details yorichi could not give him the
details himself because he had to leave
for the temple right now yorichi knew
that if he didn't leave his father would
send michikatsu off to the temple and
this would prevent his older brother
from achieving his dream of becoming a
Samurai and with their mother now gone
there would be no one there to stand up
to their father the only option now was
for eurichi to disappear and then their
father would have no choice but to
accept michikatsu as his successor
because he would be the only successor
left before leaving yorichi said a
heartfelt goodbye to his brother and he
showed michikatsu the wooden flute that
michikatsu had carved for him earlier
yorichi said that he thinks of this
flute as his brother and he will cherish
it always and keep it close to his heart
michikatsu felt that the flute was a
piece of drunk that couldn't even play
on pitch and seeing yorichi wrap it in
cloth and guard it as if it was some
kind of treasure was a surprising sight
for him to see he didn't seem to
understand why his brother felt such an
affection for him and why that stupid
flew to held so much meaning yurichi
then bowed deeply and walked off into
the night taking barely anything with
him michikatsu would later find his
mother's journal and the journal
confirmed that yorichi left for the
temple early in order to prevent their
father from making him the heir instead
of michikatsu yorichi also knew that
their mother was ill and approaching
death for years meanwhile michikatsu had
no idea their mother's illness gave her
pain on her left side in particular and
so when yorichi had been clinging to the
left side of her body he wasn't doing it
because he was a mama's boy who clung to
his mother he was doing it to help and
support her this Revelation in
particular seemed to break something
inside of michikatsu and he began to
burn with jealousy towards his brother
yorichi was not only blessed and
talented in ways that michikatsu
couldn't even imagine but he was also
such a kind and caring Soul he was
practically perfect and no person could
ever compete with such Perfection
michikatsu began wishing that his
younger brother would simply die because
his perfect existence seemed to defy the
very laws of nature yorichi was of
course right his father did want him to
replace michikatsu as his successor and
he sent men to track yorichi down at the
temple that he was supposed to go to and
to bring him back but when they arrived
at the temple yorichi wasn't there he
disappeared and no one could find him to
some extent you could understand where
the father is coming from the sengoku
period was extremely harsh and having
someone a strong and talented as yorichi
at the head of your family could ensure
the entire Clan survival while leaving
the family in the hands of a less
capable person could lead to the
destruction of the entire Clan but once
yorichi disappeared then no one could
find him their father didn't have a
choice and michikatsu became the
designated successor once again yorichi
couldn't be found at the temple because
he never went there upon leaving his
childhood home he began to run at full
speed and he didn't stop running for an
entire day and an entire night he
eventually ended up in the mountains and
despite the fact that he had run for so
many hours at full speed without resting
he didn't feel exhausted this once again
speaks to yorichi's phenomenal natural
abilities which are far beyond the
abilities of an actual human when he
finally stopped running yorichi found
himself in front of a small rice paddy
he saw a girl that was about his age and
she was just standing there with a
bucket all alone she didn't speak so
yorichi asked what she was doing there
the girl replied that her entire family
died of plague and she was left all
alone being all the way up here in the
mountains she feels very lonely so she
comes to this place to find tadpoles to
take home but then and as the sun began
to set the girl freed the tadpoles from
her bucket when yorichi asked why she
isn't going to take them home the girl
said that she felt bad about separating
them from their families yorichi felt
sympathy and compassion for this lonely
girl so he offered to walk her home the
girl's name was utta and her eyes were
like obsidian yurichi walked her home
and then he just decided to stay with
her and they began living together
yorichi was never much of a talker as we
know he didn't even say a single word
until the age of seven but Utah was just
the opposite and she loved to talk she
would talk from morning to night and it
was through talking with utta and
through listening to her talk all the
time that yorichi learned that people
see the world differently than he does
other people don't have the ability to
see through living bodies as if they
were transparent something that yurichi
was born with and so he assumed that it
was just just normal for everyone
yorichi realized that he was very
different from most people and that is
why he never fit in with others he felt
like a kite whose string had been broken
but utta was able to keep him grounded
by holding on to his hand firmly they
lived together for 10 years and then
they got married soon after that utta
got pregnant and when it was almost time
for her to give birth yorichi left the
house to find a midwife he had planned
to return Before Sunset but along the
way he found an old man who was rushing
to visit his dying son the man had a bad
heart and there was no way that he would
have made it in time to say goodbye to
his son who had been fatally injured in
battle yorichi decided to help the old
man and he was able to bring him to his
son in time but he lost many hours
because of it and he had to postpone
summoning a midwife until the following
day he rushed home but it was too late
he arrived after Sunset and while he was
away utta and his unborn child were
tragically murdered by a demon if
yorichi had returned before Sunset as he
had promised he would have been there
when the demon arrived since demons
operate at night but because yorichi was
such a caring person who wanted to help
that unfortunate old man he failed to
protect his own wife and child the
people he loved the most in this world
for 10 whole days yorichi was beside
himself as if in a daze he cradled the
bodies of his family and he wouldn't let
go finally a Demon Slayer who had been
pursuing a demon in the area stumbled
upon the house and found yorichi there
this Demon Slayer had the same hair
color as the rangoku family so we can
conclude that this Demon Slayer was the
ancestor of the flame hashira kyojuro
rengoku the Demon Slayer was finally
able to convince yorichi to give the
bodies a proper burial despite his
immense natural talents yorichi didn't
want a lot from life he wasn't ambitious
or power hungry or trying to prove
himself to anyone his dream was to live
a simple and quiet life with his family
in a house that was so small that they
could all sleep side by side and see
each other all day long that would have
been enough for yorichi but even that
humble dream couldn't come true because
demons exist in this world so yorichi
decided to become a Demon Slayer the
demon Slayers have been around as long
as the demons themselves but before
yorichi demon Slayers didn't use
breathing styles to fight and as a
result they were far weaker yorichi was
the user of the original breathing style
the breath of the Sun and this is
something that came naturally to him as
a result of his incredible talents and
abilities yorichi taught breathing
styles to the strongest Demon Slayer
years known as the hashira and this made
them much more powerful than they were
before no other Demon Slayer was ever
able to master the breath of the sun
itself it was too advanced for them but
yorichi was able to adapt the breathing
styles of each individual Slayer to
their own strengths and abilities and
that is how the first derivative
breathing Styles emerged including flame
wind water Thunder and stone breathing
suddenly these superhuman demons were
being defeated one after the other and
eventually even yorichi's older brother
michikatsu became a Demon Slayer for the
10 years that yorichi spent living with
UTA michikatsu had lived peacefully at
the family home he married and had two
children and his days were calm and even
somewhat boring time went by slowly and
he had practically forgotten about his
younger brother and he almost forgot the
extreme jealousy that he had felt
because of his brother's natural talents
but then one night I a demon attacked
the place where michikatsu and some of
his men had set up camp and before long
all of michikatsu's men were dead and he
was the only one left standing
michikatsu would have met the same fate
as his men but Demon Slayer yorichi
arrived just in time to relieve the
demon of his head and save his older
brother immediately michikatsu's
Tranquility was gone and his stomach
once again burnt with jealousy and even
hate in a mere flash yorichi
demonstrated unbelievable skills with
the sword skills that made even the
phenomenal Talent he showed as a child
seem insignificant by comparison yorichi
could now easily defeat superhuman
opponents like demons opponents who were
able to kill dozens of Samurai warriors
on their own to make things worse after
saving michikatsu's life yorichi
actually apologized he apologized for
not arriving sooner and saving all of
Michigan's men along with him yorichi
was not only a flawless swordsman but he
was also a man of flawless character and
michikatsu was reminded yet again just
how inferior he was compared to his
younger brother and even though he knew
that yorichi was far superior to him
michikatsu couldn't help wanting to
reach the same height as his brother he
even abandoned his wife and children in
order to become a Demon Slayer just like
yorichi and in order to train with
yorichi in the hopes of one day becoming
as strong as he was and so yorichi
trained michikatsu along with the other
demon Slayers and even though michikatsu
could never perfect the breath of the
sun he eventually developed the
derivative form known as Moon breathing
he also manifested the Demon Slayer Mark
along with several other demon Slayers
who had trained under yorichi and yet
even after learning a breathing style
and manifesting a mark identical to
urichi's michikatsu still couldn't catch
up to his younger brother he was much
stronger than before but still nowhere
near yorichi but then though those demon
Slayers who manifested the mark began to
die off at the age of 25. it seems that
the Mark gave demon Slayers additional
power but that power came at the cost of
their lifespan michikatsu had to face
the hard truth he was about to die
without ever catching up to his brother
his burning all-consuming jealousy would
never go away because he would die as he
had lived in his brother's Shadow and it
was in this moment of self-doubt and
Desperation that michikatsu was
approached by the progenitor of all
demons muzan kibutsuji muzan told
michikatsu that if he became a demon he
could live forever he would have all the
time in the world to get stronger and
surpass his brother and the jealousy he
felt would finally go away his lifelong
goal of catching up to yorichi would
finally be attainable and at long last
he would be able to step out of his
brother's Shadow staring in the face of
his own imminent death and facing the
prospect of ending his life as a failure
michikatsu agreed to muzan's proposal he
became the demon kokushible
but if muzon thought that he was now
safe because he was able to recruit a
Demon Slayer who used breathing Styles
into his demon ranks he was wrong soon
after he would come face to face with
none other than yorichi as soon as
yorichi laid eyes on muzon he knew that
he had been born for one reason and one
reason only to defeat the progenitor of
the demon race yorichi could feel right
away that muzan was overflowing with
violent intent looking at him felt like
looking at the magma that erupted from a
volcano he boiled and seized as if to
consume everything cocky as always muzan
told yorichi that he was no longer
interested in Swordsmen who used
breathing Styles and this was likely an
allusion to the fact that muzan had
already convinced one Demon Slayer who
used breathing michikatsu to become a
demon he obviously had no idea that
yorichi was on a completely different
level from his brother and from everyone
else but although muzan was too cocky he
certainly wasn't someone to take lightly
in fact this moment was the very first
time that yurichi felt a chill down his
spine because by looking at muzan's
movements he knew that even a single
scratch from muzon could kill him so
yorichi charged muzon's attacks as best
as he could while preparing for his own
attack using his ability to see the
transparent World yorichi saw that muzan
had seven hearts and five brains
distributed throughout his body meaning
that even the act of taking off muzan's
head would not necessarily kill him
yurichi's Only Hope was a single
decisive attack that involved perfecting
or rather completing all of the forms of
sun Breathing by rapidly and
continuously performing all 12 forms of
sun breathing the user is able to
destroy all 12 of muzan's vital organs
seven hearts and five brains this is
what is referred to as the 13th form of
sun breathing the completion and perfect
union of all 12 forms into one yorichi's
phenomenal attack caught muzon by
surprise and he was cut down and utterly
defeated he tried to regenerate but his
body wouldn't obey because yorichi was
in possession of a bright red nichidin
sword and bright red nitrogen swords
disrupt the Regeneration abilities of
demons yurichi looked down on the
defeated demon who was laying on the
ground in shock and he asked what is the
value of a life to you muzan didn't
answer his face just turned a dark shade
of red and it looked like he was about
to explode with rage yorichi then
glanced over to a female demon who had
been standing next to muzon when the
battle first began yorichi thought that
this female demon might try to help
muzan so he was prepared to fight her
too but to his surprise the girl didn't
try to help she simply stood there and
stared at muzon's mangled body as if
hoping that he would actually be
destroyed Right Here and Now yorichi
determined that the girl wasn't a threat
so he prepared to finish off muzon for
good but as yorichi stepped towards the
demon he heard the sound of muzan's
teeth grinding muzan was about to use
the very last trick up his sleep his
final desperate attempt to survive this
encounter with the strongest Demon
Slayer muzon made his own body explode
into 1800 pieces and disperse all over
the forest yorichi reacted quickly and
he was able to cut down more than 1500
of those 1800 pieces of flesh but the
rest were too small and they managed to
squirm away once they got away from
yorichi these pieces combined into a
lump the size of a human head and so
muzon managed to survive and eventually
to regenerate the female demon dropped
down to her knees and began to weep
yorichi was so close to destroying muzon
which is exactly what she had been
hoping for but muzan was able to
overcome even the act of being beheaded
and he somehow managed to continue
living yet again the girl was beyond
distraught she was crying and pulling
out her hair in frustration despite
being a demon she hated it moves on as
much as anyone this female demon fully
expected to die now because she had so
clearly disobeyed muzan but for some
reason nothing happened to her perhaps
muzan was too weak now to try and hurt
her or control her when she calmed down
a bit she told yorichi that muzan will
probably never face yorichi again he
almost died and he will now be terrified
so he will hide out and wait for yarichi
to die a natural death before
re-emerging being Immortal muzon has all
the Time in the World to wait it out but
yorichi doesn't sooner or later he will
die since the female demon was free from
muzan's control yorichi asked her to
help him find and defeat the demon
progenitor once and for all she agreed
and she revealed that her name is Tamayo
this is the same Tamayo that is still
alive and working to defeat muzon to
this day it was only after this
confrontation with muzan that yorichi
learned from his fellow demon Slayers
that his own brother michikatsu decided
to become a demon despite being the
strongest Demon Slayer yorichi failed to
defeat muzon he allowed Tamayo to escape
unharmed even though she was a demon and
his own twin brother betrayed the demon
Slayers and willingly became a demon as
a result of these failures yorichi was
banished from the Demon's air core some
Demon Slayers even suggested that he
should take his own life in order to
atone for his failures but the young
leader of the ubayashiki family and of
the demon sire Corps at the time would
not allow it yorichi truly felt that he
was born with this exceptional strength
skill and talent for the sole purpose of
defeating muzan but now that muzan was
hiding from him he felt that he had
failed in the very task that he had been
born to do that is why yorichi is so
depressed during his first official
introduction in chapter 99 and that is
why he calls himself a man without value
who failed to accomplish published to
one thing that he was meant to do in
this life that is why he calls himself
worthless thankfully yorichi's friend
sumioshi his wife suyako and their young
children were able to be there for
yurichi and to cheer him up when he
needed it the most he eventually told
sumioshi his entire life story and he
taught him how to perform all of the
forms of sun breathing which would then
be passed on from generation to
generation within sumiyoshi's family as
the dance of the fire god hinokami
kagura yorichi visited his friend
sumioshi several times and on his last
visit he gifted sumiyoshi the hanafura
earings that his mother had made for him
as a child these earrings would also be
passed down through the generations
along with the hinokamikagura until they
finally made their way to tanjiro
himself on the day that yorichi left
sumioshi and his family for the final
time tantiro's ancestor told yorichi
that he saved their lives and he
promised to carry on his legacy through
through the future generations of their
family sumiyoshi told yorichi that his
life is not without value and that he
won't let anyone say that about him
yurichi smiled and thanked sumioshi and
his family and then he waved and
disappeared forever but even though he
was banished from the demon Slayers
yurichi continued to fight against
demons on his own for the better part of
the next 60 years even though he was
born with the Demon Slayer Mark yorichi
didn't die at the age of 25. instead he
lived well into his 80s and eventually
he would come face to face with his own
demon brother michikatsu now known as
the upper Moon one kokushible the fact
that yurichi was still alive despite
having the Demon Slayer Mark again
emphasized the fact that yorichi was
special and more gifted than his brother
now a demon kokushibo of course didn't
age and he was still at Peak strength
when he met his brother for the final
time meanwhile yorichi was now a frail
old man who inhabited a weak human body
rather than an immortal demon by body
and yet yorichi pittied what his twin
brother had become michikatsu thought
that yorichi was now just an ugly and
frail old creature and yet yorichi
actually cried and expressed pity and
sympathy for michikatsu yorichi was the
one who pitied michikatsu not the other
way around however in the next moment
yorichi's sympathy and sentimentality
ceased he assumed his Battle Stance and
a heavy aura of intimidation filled the
air there were no flaws or openings in
yorichi's stance and he even announced
to kokokushibu when he would attack but
kokushibu still couldn't stop it
yurichi's form was still Flawless his
son breathing was still Godlike and even
after six decades yorichi was still
stronger than kokushibo his technique
was so incredible that he defeated the
demon kokushi boat despite being an
octogenarian kokushiba was severely
injured by the elderly eurichi's attack
back and he knew that with the very next
attack yorichi would cut him down and
end his life forever
nevertheless yorichi passed away from
old age before he had a chance to strike
the finishing blow against kokushibo now
well into his 80s yorichi died of
natural causes but he died standing he
died on his feet kokushibu survived at
the battle but he was forced to live
another 400 years with the knowledge
that even as an old man yorichi was
still stronger than him to make things
even worse when kokushibu angrily cut
down yorichi's lifeless body he found
the small wooden flute that he had made
for his brother back when they were
children despite the fact that kokuchipo
had betrayed the Demon Slayer core and
despite the fact that he became a
ruthless demon yorichi still treasured
that defective little flute that his
twin brother had made for him all those
years ago so Not only was was yorichi
stronger than kokushibu even in his 80s
but he still remained a man of flawless
character and endless compassion until
the very end yorichi was always able to
see the beauty of this world in spite of
all its flaws and cruelties even after
he lost his family at the hands of a
demon even after he lost his brother to
treachery even after he failed to
destroy muzan it was banished from the
Demon Slayer Corps yorichi was still
able to see Beauty in this world he saw
it in sumioshi and his family in the
innocent Embrace of sumioshi's daughter
and in the smiles on the faces of the
people he helped yorichi always remained
faithful to his principles and he fought
against the demons for nearly 80 years
he was never tempted to become a demon
himself and he never compromised his own
dignity and integrity he still cherished
the memory of his brother even though
that brother turned his back on
everything even his own humanity and
became a cruel and ruthless villain
unrecognizable inhuman monster referring
to yorichi muzon famously said the real
monster is that mad not me and in some
ways muzon isn't exactly wrong humans
are flawed and imperfect and they are
often scared and angry and hypocritical
in that sense muzon the progenitor of
the Demons is far more human than
yorichi muzan acted like he was a
superior being but he was also terrified
of death at the same time he ran away
and hid from yorichi rather than face
him again and he was willing to destroy
everyone and everything in his path just
so he would one day be free from his
crippling fear of death but yorichi's
character is almost Divine not only did
he have superhuman strength and talent
but he had a Flawless moral character
and a Heart full of kindness and
compassion no amount of evil or tragedy
could ever take that kindness and
compassion out of your Ichi and nothing
could prevent him from seeing the beauty
of this world beauty that is all around
us due to his incredible god-given
powers and abilities yurichi's life was
in many ways a miracle but yorichi
teaches us that all life is a miracle
and that we are all so lucky to have
been born into this world we cannot
forget that without yurichi muzan and
the demons would never have been
defeated sumioshi would have died
tanjiro never would have been born and
breathing Styles would not have been a
thing without yorichi no demon Sarah
would have ever learned to use breathing
techniques and so they would have been
far less effective against the demons in
battle frankly it's likely that the
Demon Slayer core would have gone
extinct long before the taisho period
even began finally Tamayo never would
have been able to break free of muzan's
control and eventually contribute to his
ultimate downfall if it wasn't for
yorichi yorichi was certainly the
strongest demons in history but in many
ways he is also the most important
character in all of Demon Slayer because
without yorichi tsugikuni this story
that we know and love would not have
been possible
if you liked this video on yorichi and
his backstory then don't miss my video
on the backstory of every known hashira
in Demon Slayer Link in the description
and on screen if you guys enjoyed this
Demon Slayer video and you want to see
more in the future leave a click like
and comment right now and if you enjoyed
the video but you haven't taken the time
to subscribe to the channel yet do me a
big favor and subscribe right now and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications